So, from the last problem, we were able to figure out that x equals 3. But what
if the exponent is not known? What if we had this equation? This second
equation is called an exponential equation. It's called that since the exponent
is the variable, and it's unknown. But we can apply similar reasoning. Let's
take 27 and write it with a base of 3. We can rewrite 27 as 3 to the third
power. And since these two bases are the same. We know the exponents must be
equal in order for the two numbers to be the same. So here we know that this x
must equal this exponent. X must equal 3. In general, whenever we have x to the
a, equal x to the b, we know that the exponents a and b must be equal, since
their bases are equal. This works in general so long as x, which is the base,
is not equal to 0 or 1. So for an equation like this, what do you think x
equals? Write it here.